(regal music)
(processional drumming)
(processional music)
- Good morning.
To our newest class of scholars,
welcome to Yale.
I'm delighted to join
your dean, Dean Cooley,
and other members of the Yale community
in marking the beginning of
your graduate studies at Yale.
You know, I was in your
position back in 1981.
I came to Yale as a graduate
student from Stanford.
I had worked in the Bay Area for a year.
And when I arrived here,
I had a pretty clear understanding
of the work I wanted to
do in graduate school.
And I'm sure many of you do as well.
But I really had no idea how
much Yale would shape my life,
both professionally and personally.
I also really couldn't have
predicted my career trajectory,
but that's another story.
As a graduate student,
I knew I wanted to be
a clinically-trained social psychologist,
to study human emotion,
and, eventually, my goal was to have
a research group and a laboratory.
But I never would've thought
that the mentoring I received,
the insights I gained,
and the relationships I
developed would lead here.
In graduate school,
I didn't foresee that what I'd learned
would one day help me serve,
serve this wonderful university,
a beautiful, complex
community of individuals
from all walks of life.
Ironically, although I came here
to conduct research on emotion
and that later led to work
on emotional intelligence,
my mentors in the psychology department
led me to study, as well,
how people process
information about health
and how to design messages about health
that motivate people
to protect their health
and the health of others.
Here we are, at the end
of a pandemic, I hope,
and that experience has come in handy.
So each of these lines of work
seems so applicable at the present moment,
but it's all more than
I really could imagine
at the time I was in graduate school.
Well, I don't have to tell you
how unpredictable this
world of ours can be.
The COVID-19 pandemic has
reshaped our lives and our society
in ways that few of us could imagine.
There are many changes we
made during the last two years
that we're going to keep in place.
We call them COVID keepers, right?
Place has permanently changed.
COVID-19 has reshaped our lives.
Alongside this historic
public health crisis,
we've also witnessed a national
reckoning around racism.
We've witnessed the perils
of conflict and political upheaval.
We've witnessed the continued impact
of climate change on our planet.
In the midst of this kind of turbulence,
we know that the world needs solutions
from the kinds of research and scholarship
you will be conducting at Yale.
However, because we've seen how quickly
our routines and plans can be upended,
we know that it would be unwise
to think we can completely
map out our paths in life.
Instead of being weighed
down by uncertainty, though,
be open to the possibilities ahead.
View each unexpected challenge
as a potential to create a change in you
and in the communities
of which you are a part.
As you embark on your studies at Yale,
you will gain knowledge and skills
that are expected of an
excellent graduate education,
but you will also have opportunities
to develop new interests
and explore unplanned avenues
of inquiry along the way.
Look for those moments.
Look for those moments
because you never know
how significant they will be for you,
for your local community, for
your country, for the world.
All of you have come here with
ideas of what you want to do,
but keep your eyes open
for unexpected paths
that may unfold for you.
Since the beginning of the pandemic,
I've been reminded of the
importance of being receptive
to unforeseen possibilities.
Every time I've seen Yale
graduate Francis Collins
speak about efforts to
control the spread of COVID.
Many of you know, Dr. Collins
is the acting science advisor
to President Biden.
He was formerly the director
of the National Institutes of Health,
and he's one of the country's
most respected physician-scientists
and public health authorities.
Now, when he was starting
his graduate studies,
right here at Yale,
he was in physical chemistry,
and he said he had no interest
in medicine or biology.
In fact, he thought biology
was chaotic and unpredictable.
Sorry, for those of you going into biology
like our provost and our dean.
(students and faculty chuckle)
That all changed.
He took a course in biochemistry.
It inspired in him a deep
interest in genetics,
and that led him to
alter his career paths.
That one biochemistry course
at Yale as a graduate student
became an unexpected
turning point in his life.
He went on to contribute
to the identification
of the cystic fibrosis gene,
that led to the development of a therapy
that could help tens
of thousands of people
living with this disease.
He was also at the helm of
the Human Genome Project,
which has given us a detailed knowledge
about the structure and
function of our genes.
And in recent years,
he spearheaded efforts to stop a pandemic.
What unassuming course
could change your views
or set you on a new path
in the coming years?
What could it mean to the world?
Not all moments of inspiration
will happen inside a library
or a classroom or a
laboratory or a lecture hall,
although I hope many will, but
that is why I hope you will
immerse yourself fully
in the Yale community.
I think of recent graduates
who often point to experiences
outside of their departments
that led them in new
and fruitful directions.
Lucy Armentado, who received her PhD
in psychology last year, my department,
said that serving as the chair
of the Graduate Student Assembly
was her most meaningful and
rewarding experience at Yale,
at least one of the most.
GSA, she said, was really formative
in her identity as a graduate student.
She said, "I never
really thought of myself
as an advocate or leader until GSA.
And then being GSA chair
was the most incredible thing
I've done professionally.
It was a pinnacle."
Andrew Schartmann came to Yale
with a special interest in music pedagogy.
He joined the New England
Conservatory's faculty
after he received his
PhD here in music theory.
Yet it was a peer in his
graduate class here at Yale
that got him involved in the
Yale School of Medicine project
designed to promote healthy
lives among young adults
through virtual reality.
So in addition to his
teaching of music theory,
Andrew now serves as the audio director
of the medical school's Play4REAL XR lab,
crafting a sound environment
for virtual reality games
and mobilizing his musical prowess
in support of public health.
I think of a student named Edgar Garcia,
whose academic career, as he said,
took some unexpected turns along the way.
He came prepared to study
early American poetics,
but then a fellowship
at the Beinecke Library
changed the focus of his PhD work
to 20th century poetics
and Latinx literature.
Edgar said the resources of the Beinecke
made 20th century poetics
more materially resonant,
and that his English department
mentors and colleagues
were fully supportive of his
newfound academic interests.
I think you get the idea.
You will find that some of
your most memorable moments
may happen in even more unexpected places.
I was recently reading an
article about Patrick Njoroge.
He's the governor of the
central bank of Kenya.
And he received this PhD in
economics at Yale in 1993.
And he was talking about
the valuable mentorship
that he received from faculty members
like James Tobin and William Brainard.
But he also was reminiscing
about attending the Yale-Harvard
football game in 1987.
"It was cold," he said.
"It was the coldest day that
I had ever faced in my life.
It was subzero with a windchill factor.
I don't even remember who won.
Survival was the only thing on my mind."
But survive he did.
And he used his Yale education
to help foster economic
opportunity and improve the lives
of people in Kenya and across
the continent of Africa.
Be open. Be open to
the options before you.
Be curious about the work and interests
of your peers across departments,
You'll find that Yale fosters
the kind of environment
that encourages you to pursue
what you came here to do,
but also offers unexpected ways
for you to expand your horizons,
if you immerse yourself
in the intellectual,
social, and cultural life
of the university as a whole.
And don't forget,
it's also a place you will
make wonderful friends
and find lifelong mentors.
I just had lunch two weeks ago
with my graduate school office mate,
who sat at a desk next
to me for four years
in the basement of Kirtland Hall
in the psychology department.
We've been friends for 40 years.
I also met Marta, my wife,
when we were both
graduate students at Yale.
And in 1986, in May, I
submitted my dissertation,
in June, we got married,
and in July, I started
on the faculty here.
So it was a time of great transition,
but it was the beginning of
the next phase of my wife,
my life,
(audience chuckles)
also my wife.
Marta, why don't you
stand up for a minute,
and just so people can
see who you are, yeah.
(students and faculty applaud)
People think the new dean
of Yale College and I
are the shortest people on campus,
but in fact, Marta is really
wearing that with great pride.
Well, in the coming years, you will learn.
You will grow.
You will find surprising
opportunities and challenges.
I guarantee that.
But what I can't predict is
what you will do ultimately
with your Yale graduate education,
with the knowledge, with the
expertise, with the experience,
with the wisdom you will gain.
What we do know is that Yale graduates
have gone on to lead in business,
in science, in technology,
in the arts, and in the humanities.
They are leaving their mark.
They are realizing
Yale's vision and mission
to educate aspiring leaders worldwide,
who serve all sectors of society.
It's gonna go quickly.
Before you know it, you will be graduating
and you will take your ideas and dreams,
incubated at Yale.
You will take them and bring
them to life in novel ways.
I'm counting on you to
improve the world today
and for future generations.
I can't wait to see what you
are all going to accomplish.
And on behalf of all of my
colleagues here on stage with me,
we welcome you to Yale.
(students and faculty applaud)
Thank you.
And now it is a great pleasure
for me to welcome you,
once again, by introducing
you to your dean, Lynn Cooley.
Your dean, now in her second term
as the Dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences,
she's a tireless advocate
for graduate students,
a powerful agent of change
in graduate education
here at Yale.
Dean Cooley is the C.N.H.
Long Professor of Genetics.
She's also a Professor of Cell Biology
and of Molecular, Cellular,
and Developmental Biology.
And she's the Vice Provost
for Postdoctoral Affairs.
She was, for many years,
the director of Yale's Combined Program
in the Biological and Biomedical Sciences
Dean Cooley earned her BA
from Connecticut College,
her PhD from the University of Texas,
and she carried out research
with Sterling Professor Dieter Soll,
here in Yale's Department
of Molecular Biophysics
and Biochemistry.
After post-doctoral training
at the Carnegie Institution of Science,
she joined the Yale faculty
to study cellular mechanisms
underlying female and male fertility.
She's been recognized
with a Pew Scholar Award
from the Pew Charitable Trust.
She's a member of the Connecticut Academy
for Science and Engineering
and a fellow of the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
She served on the board
of the Genetics Society
of America for many years,
and she was the president in 2017.
In the spirit of my speech just now,
Dean Cooley has many other interests.
She's an avid member of the
Appalachian Mountain Club.
She's a student of modern dance.
She's a devoted mother of two daughters,
who are both Yale graduates.
And it gives me great pleasure
to introduce you to your dean
and one of Yale's
outstanding faculty members,
Lynn Cooley.
(students and faculty applaud)
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, President Salovey,
for your remarks and that
wonderful introduction.
Good morning, distinguished colleagues,
and good morning to you,
new master's degree
students, doctoral students,
and visiting students
in the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences.
We are thrilled to welcome you
as the newest members of our community.
You should be proud of all your hard work
that brought you here today.
With deep gratitude and respect,
I want to begin by acknowledging
the indigenous peoples and nations,
including Mohegan, Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Schaghticoke, Golden
Hill Paugussett, Niantic,
and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquian speaking peoples,
who have stewarded through generations
the lands and waterways of what is now
the state of Connecticut
and Yale University.
We honor the enduring
relationship that exists
between these peoples
and nations and this land
and recognize that this relationship
is as much a part of our history
as it is a part of our present and future.
Graduate students,
you were selected to be here
because you have proven
abilities and unlimited promise.
You are here because our faculty
recognized your intellectual
curiosity and creativity,
your academic drive and rigor,
your passion for discovery,
and your potential for leadership.
You are here because
we believe you can make
valuable contributions to
both Yale and the world,
and because we know Yale can help you
on your path to intellectual growth.
We're delighted you
have chosen to join us.
The graduate school is at the very heart
of Yale's mission as a university.
Our mission is to
educate graduate students
to seek answers to life's
most challenging questions.
As you join us here today,
you are setting off on
a chapter of your life
that will allow you to
explore a field in depth,
master an area of inquiry,
and learn to disseminate knowledge
within and beyond the classroom.
This year's incoming class
in the graduate school
has 535 doctoral students
and 219 master's students.
Collectively, you represent 54 countries
and 39 states of the United States,
plus Washington, D.C., and Puerto Rico.
54% of you are international students.
You will be working across
the graduate school's
more than 70 departments and programs.
But whatever your area of study may be,
proteins or poetry,
ecosystems or solar systems,
you all share a common motivation.
You're driven by the desire to learn more,
by the thrill of discovering
new truths about our world,
and by the desire to
stretch your imagination
and create new knowledge.
So reflecting on the
composition of this class,
I can tell you,
Yale is fortunate to
gather the best students
from across the globe.
Which means, if you look around you,
you come from all walks of life,
backgrounds, and identities.
The graduate school is committed
to creating an environment
in which all of you can thrive and excel,
Partly because we value
diversity, equity, inclusion,
and belonging as a core
principle of the university,
but also because research shows
that groups who embody these qualities
are better investigators
and smarter thinkers.
I had my own eye-opening experience
as a graduate student many years ago,
when I found myself in a laboratory
where I was one of a small
minority of Americans,
surrounded by people
from all over the world.
I learned things like a few
phrases in German and Japanese,
but I also learned that
each of our backgrounds
and experiences meant
we could each contribute
in our own ways to the culture of the lab.
My lab mates got a kick out
of learning some phrases
in American Sign Language from me.
I still remember when one of
the postdocs I greatly admired
realized his experiment
had crashed for the day.
And instead of being forlorn,
he grinned at me across the lab
and signed, "Free day," and left.
His reaction showed me
that the give-and-take
of different languages
helped create an atmosphere of trust
in which we could comfortably share
research ideas and anything else,
no matter how crazy they seemed.
It also showed me it was
okay to take some free time
when you hit a temporary roadblock.
Both were valuable lessons to me
as a young person in a new environment.
It can be overwhelming
to start this new chapter in your life.
You're in a new city, for most of you,
meeting lots of new people,
and figuring out how to navigate
the first steps of graduate school.
Trust that you belong here.
Trust that bringing your whole self
will make everything better.
Trust that you will contribute positively
to the people around you,
based on your experiences
and perspectives.
Learn to listen.
Learn when to listen and when to speak up,
to put yourself out there
and start conversations with
people you don't know yet.
Over the next few days,
be intentional about meeting new people
and be open to building
relationships with them.
Some of those relationships
may lead to future collaborations
and other may lead to lifelong
friends or even marriage.
The human connections you form,
be they personal or professional,
will sustain you.
These human connections can also help you
when discussing fraught or
complex issues with your peers.
Yale is committed to the
free exchange of ideas,
and it is the foundation upon
which the university exists
in its educational enterprise.
Yale's official statement
on freedom of expression,
commonly referred to
as the Woodward Report,
makes the following
statement that I quote,
"By voluntarily taking up
membership in a university
and thereby asserting a claim
to its rights and privileges,
members also acknowledge the existence
of certain obligations upon
themselves and their fellows.
Above all, every member of the
university has an obligation
to permit free expression
in the university.
No member has a right to
prevent such expression,"
close quote.
Questioning your assumptions
about what you currently know
will broaden your
understanding of the world,
both in the classroom
and in your interactions
with those you encounter
in your daily lives.
You have made it to graduate school
because you excelled intellectually,
but Yale is a place
that requires you to be
emotionally intelligent as well.
You may hear passionate
opinions about campus issues
or issues playing out across the country
and around the world.
Be willing to listen to a range of views
and develop your own opinions,
even if it means agreeing to
disagree from time to time.
Disagreement does not inhibit growth
or disregard mutual respect.
We cannot lose sight of
our collective humanity.
If you feel a bit unsure
about what is to come,
this is absolutely normal.
In fact, that feeling is
the perfect starting point
for what you have come here to do.
Your time in graduate school
is very much about getting comfortable
with uncertainty and dwelling
at the edge of the unknown.
Don't think we have a
single word for that state,
but we can describe it as
a tolerance for ambiguity.
The romantic poet, John Keats,
called it negative capability,
or the capacity to thrive
in the midst of uncertainty and doubt.
It may sound like an unpleasant state,
but Keats and others after him
understood negative capability
as a positive prerequisite
for discovery and creativity.
One of our aims in the graduate school
is to help you develop
the negative capability
you need to be comfortable
when faced with uncertainty and mystery,
to become the scholars and
researchers you aspire to be,
who can push forward the boundaries
of what we know and
understand about the world.
That search can truly be
disconcerting and difficult,
but don't insist on certainty
where there is none.
Nothing great comes out of
being entirely comfortable
all the time.
Some days will just not go as planned.
Theories and experiments may not take you
where you expect to go.
I have learned this
lesson over and over again
in my time as a research scientist.
In fact, the most exciting days in my lab
are when an unexpected result
leads to a brand new area.
Most recently, investigating
the function of a gene
required for egg development
and fertility in females
has led us to studying
brain-specific protein synthesis
in a way that wasn't possible before.
I never would've imagined that transition.
The network you create
and the departmental home you have joined
will give you the support you need
to survive and thrive in graduate school.
You will find that graduate
school is very different
from your previous experiences.
You will be much more responsible
for your own education
than you ever have been before.
Your schedules will be less predictable
than they were in the past.
This is not an easy endeavor,
and it isn't meant to be one.
There will be challenges
and obstacles ahead,
but trust that you will move forward.
If you start to think you're in it alone,
remember you are surrounded
by mentors and advocates,
in the form of faculty members,
many of whom are here with me today,
staff and peers, just
look around the lawn here.
The peers that you will find here,
along with faculty and staff,
are here to support you and
offer advice when you need it.
Look to those around you
for inspiration and guidance
and you will find it.
You're are about to embark
on a marathon, not a sprint.
Pace yourself.
Be kind to yourself and others,
and ask for help when you need it.
Though obstacles will exist,
great solutions to the world's
most challenging problems
will emerge from your time here.
As graduate students,
you hold a special place
in the university landscape
at the intersection of all
the research and teaching
happening across campus.
You're not simply here to
learn from the faculty.
You're here to learn with them.
Your fresh insights and
persistent curiosity
are the catalysts
to new ways of thinking,
learning, and creating.
We are eager to witness and celebrate
all that you will accomplish.
And the world will be waiting
for you to come out and
share what you've learned,
as soon as you're ready.
The empathy you develop
from being immersed
in a diverse community
will better position you
to offer solutions in ways
that promote peace and dignity
for all concerned.
You will become better communicators
in order to share your findings
with colleagues in your own field,
but very importantly,
the lay public as well.
Recent history has shown us
that we all must devote energy
toward helping leaders make decisions
based on fact and insight.
I want to echo President Salovey
by encouraging you to participate
fully in our community
in ways that suit your personal
and academic goals best.
During your orientation week,
you'll learn there are many
student clubs, institutes,
and organizations to explore.
You will undoubtedly be able to find
one or more that match your interest.
If you're interested in student advocacy,
truly improving the lives
of your fellow graduate
students during your time,
the Graduate Student Assembly, or GSA,
works closely with my office
to identify student priorities
and address them as quickly as possible.
Lucy Armentado, who
President Salovey mentioned,
was an incredible leader during
her time leading the GSA.
Throughout the pandemic,
my office collaborated
with GSA representatives
to respond to student needs,
such as increased stipends,
enhanced childcare support,
and improved mental health resources.
We accomplished these things together
through trust, collaboration, and honesty.
Student government works here,
and I urge you to participate.
As you become immersed in your research
and in our community,
I also encourage you
to keep your eye on
your future after Yale .
Though this is your first
official day of graduate school,
it is not too early to start
investigating and planning
your next chapter.
Visit our Office of Career
Strategy for programs and advice
about careers within
and beyond the academy.
They provide invaluable guidance,
professional development,
and concrete plans of action
for anyone building a career.
The graduate school also
has highly accomplished
and dedicated alumni who come
back to Yale to help you.
Later this year,
you will be hearing about
the Alumni Association's
"Where Do I Go from Yale" workshop
held each spring semester.
This will give you a chance to see
what our amazing alumni are doing.
People who were once sitting
right where you are today.
They can inspire your work
and give you ideas for the future.
Until then, tap into
our vast alumni network
through the Cross Campus platform.
It's a great way to make connections
with alumni in your fields of interest
who are willing to offer advice, ideas,
and all the wisdom of
someone who has been there.
They are great people and
they can open your eyes
to opportunities you may
not have considered yet.
To close, today is the
start of an exciting journey
for all of you graduate students.
Seize the opportunities to
grow, to challenge yourself,
and be sure to celebrate
not only your own successes,
but those of your colleagues and friends.
Yale will have an impact on you,
but you will also have
an impact on this campus.
And after you graduate,
on all sectors of society.
We welcome you to this community
and we look forward to all
that's in store for you.
(students and faculty applaud)
Okay, now it's for a
little bit of entertainment
and to demonstrate
that graduate students
do have fun sometimes,
I am very pleased to welcome
the graduate school's own
acapella group, The Citations.
(students and faculty applaud)
(pitch pipe resonates)
♪ Way down, way down in New Haven town ♪
♪ Lives Mr. Yale ♪
♪ Old Eli Yale ♪
♪ No one ever cares to come around ♪
♪ Just because of his pet, bow, wow ♪
♪ Grr, woof ♪
♪ Poor, old Harvard tries it once a year ♪
♪ Always goes back ♪
♪ Tied up in black ♪
♪ For when old Yale sics
that old bulldog on ♪
♪ He raises an awful row ♪
♪ You hear that ♪
♪ Bulldog, bulldog, bow, wow, wow ♪
♪ Eli Yale, doo, doo, heh, heh, heh ♪
♪ Our team can never fail ♪
♪ Old Eli Yale ♪
♪ When the son's of Eli
break through the line ♪
♪ You know that that is the sign we hail ♪
♪ Doo, doo, meow, no ♪
♪ Bulldog, bulldog, bow, wow, wow ♪
♪ Eli Yale ♪
♪ Eli, Eli Yale, Eli Yale ♪
♪ Woof ♪
(students and faculty applaud)
- Thank you, and good morning.
We are The Citations,
the oldest, the finest,
the most melodious,
and the only graduate
and professional student
acapella group here at Yale.
We're so excited to be
here with you this morning.
We have a few selections,
starting with a homegrown mashup
on the theme of volcanoes.
And we hope you enjoy.
(pitch pipe resonates)
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ When Rome's in ruins
♪ ♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ We are the lions ♪
♪ Free of the Colosseum ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ In poison places, we are anti-venom ♪
♪ We're the beginning of the end ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ Tonight, the foxes hunt the hounds ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
♪ Before it has begun ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ We've already won ♪
♪ We are ♪
♪ We are wild ♪
♪ We are like ♪
♪ Young volcanoes ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ We are, we are ♪
♪ Wild ♪
♪ Americana ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ Exotica ♪
♪ Do you wanna feel a
little beautiful, baby? ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Ba, da, ba, da, ba ♪
♪ I was there ♪
♪ In my own devices ♪
♪ Ba, ba, ba, da, ba, ba ♪
♪ Ba, ba, ba, da, ba, da, ba, ba ♪
♪ Many days fell away
with nothing to show ♪
♪ And the walls ♪
♪ Kept tumbling down ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ In the city that we love ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ Grey clouds ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Roll over the hills ♪
♪ Ooh, ahh ♪
♪ Bringing darkness from above ♪
♪ But if you close your eyes ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Does it almost feel like ♪
♪ Nothing changed at all ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ And if you close your eyes ♪
♪ Does if almost feel ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ You've been here before ♪
♪ How am I gonna be an
optimist about this ♪
♪ Ba, ba, da, da ♪
♪ How am I gonna be an
optimist about this ♪
♪ Ba, ba, da, da ♪
♪ We were caught up ♪
♪ and lost ♪
♪ In all of our vices ♪
♪ C'mon, make it easy ♪
♪ In your pose as the dust ♪
♪ Settled around us ♪
♪ Say I never mattered ♪
♪ Run it up the flagpole ♪
♪ And the walls kept tumbling
down in the city that we love ♪
♪ Tonight, the foxes hunt the hounds ♪
♪ Rain clouds roll over the hills ♪
♪ Bringing darkness from above ♪
♪ We've already won ♪ ♪ We are
wild ♪ ♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ We are like young volcanoes ♪
♪ We are wild ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Americana, exotica ♪
♪ Do you wanna feel ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh ♪
♪ A little beautiful, baby? ♪
♪ Eh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, where do we begin ♪
♪ The rubble or our sins ♪
♪ And the walls ♪
♪ Oh, where do ♪
♪ Come tumbling down ♪
♪ We begin ♪
♪ In the city that we love
♪ ♪ The rubble or our sins ♪
♪ Grey clouds ♪
♪ Oh, where do ♪
♪ Roll over the hills ♪
♪ We begin ♪
♪ Bringing darkness from above ♪
♪ The rubble or our sins ♪
♪ But if you close your eyes ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Does it almost feel like ♪
♪ Nothing changed at all ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ And if you close your eyes ♪
♪ Does it almost feel like ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ You've been here before ♪
♪ How am I gonna be ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ An optimist about this ♪
♪ How am I gonna be ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ An optimist about this ♪
♪ If you close your eyes
♪ ♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Does it almost feel like ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Nothing ♪
♪ Changed at all ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Eh, eh, oh, eh, oh ♪
(students and faculty applaud)
(pitch pipe resonates)
♪ I've heard there was a secret chord ♪
♪ That David played, and
it pleased the Lord ♪
♪ But you don't ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Really care for music ♪
♪ Do you ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Well, it goes like this ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ The fourth, the fifth ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ The minor falls ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ The major lifts ♪
♪ The baffled king ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Composing Hallelujah ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, Hallelujah ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Da, da, doom, da, da, doom ♪
♪ Da, da, doom ♪
♪ Well your faith was strong ♪
♪ But you needed proof ♪
♪ Da, da, doom ♪
♪ You saw her bathing ♪
♪ On the roof ♪
♪ Da, da, doom ♪
♪ Her beauty ♪
♪ And her moonlight ♪
♪ Da doom ♪
♪ Overthrew ya' ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ooh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ She tied you to ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ The kitchen chair ♪
♪ Ah, ah ♪
♪ She broke your throne ♪
♪ And she cut your hair ♪
♪ Ah, ah ♪
♪ And from your lips ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ She drew the Hallelujah ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, Hallelujah ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Da, da, doom, da da doom ♪
♪ Well, maybe I've ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Been here before ♪
♪ I've seen this room ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ And I've walked this floor ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah, oh, oh ♪
♪ I used to live alone ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Before I knew ya' ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ And I've seen your flag ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ On the marble arch ♪
♪ And love is not ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ A victory march ♪
♪ Oh, oh, a victory march ♪
♪ It's a cold ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ And it's a broken Hallelujah ♪
♪ Ah, Hallelujah ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Oh, Hallelujah ♪
♪ Maybe there's a God above ♪
♪ But all I've ever ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ Learned from love ♪
♪ Is how to shoot ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ At someone who outdrew ya' ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ah, ah ♪
♪ But it's not a crime ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ That you hear at night ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Not somebody ♪
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Who's seen the light ♪
♪ Ah, ah, whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ It's a cold and it's
a broken Hallelujah ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
(singers humming)
(students and faculty applaud)
- Thank you so much.
I wanna make a quick plug here
that we'll be having auditions
for all graduate and
professional school students
this September.
Please look us up
if you'd like to be up here next year,
if you'd like to join us.
We have one more song before we go.
It's a classic by Queen.
We hope you enjoy.
(pitch pipe resonates)
♪ Can anybody ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Doo, doo, da, da, da ♪
♪ Each morning I get up ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ I die a little ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Can barely stand on my feet ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Take a look ♪
♪ Take a look at yourself ♪
♪ In the mirror and cry ♪
♪ Oh, Lord, what you're ♪
♪ And cry ♪
♪ Doing to me? ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Oh, I have spent all ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ My years in believing you ♪
♪ Ooh, 'lieve you ♪
♪ But I just can't get no relief, Lord ♪
♪ Somebody, oh, somebody ♪
♪ Somebody, somebody ♪
♪ Can anybody find me ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
♪ Da, da ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, da, da, da ♪
♪ I work hard ♪
♪ He works hard ♪
♪ Every day of my life ♪
♪ Doo, doo ♪
♪ I work 'til I ache ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ In my bones ♪
♪ Doo, doo ♪
♪ At the end ♪
♪ At the end of the day ♪
♪ Doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ I take home ♪
♪ Doo, doo ♪
♪ My hard earned pay ♪
♪ Ahh, ahh ♪
♪ All on my own ♪
♪ I get down on my knees ♪
♪ Down, knees ♪
♪ And I start to pray ♪
♪ Start to pray ♪
♪ 'Til the tears ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Will run down from my eyes ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Lord, somebody, oh somebody ♪
♪ Somebody ♪
♪ Oh, can anybody ♪
♪ Please, anybody ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Find me, da, da ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, da, da, da ♪
♪ He works hard ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Every day ♪
♪ And I've tried and I've
tried and I've tried ♪
♪ But everybody wants ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ To put me down ♪
♪ They say I'm going crazy ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ They say I got a lot
of water on my brain ♪
♪ And I've got no common sense
♪ ♪ I've got ♪ ♪ He's got ♪
♪ Nobody left to believe ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, da, da ♪
♪ Da, da, da ♪
♪ Got no feel, I got no rhythm ♪
♪ I just keep losing my beat ♪
♪ Doo, doo ♪
♪ You just keep losing ♪
♪ He just keep losing ♪
♪ It's okay, I'm all right ♪
♪ And losing ♪
♪ He's alright, he's alright ♪
♪ I ain't gonna face no defeat ♪
♪ I just gotta get out ♪
♪ You gotta get out ♪
♪ Of this prison cell ♪
♪ Someday, I'm gonna be free, Lord ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ Find me, find me, find me ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ Somebody, somebody ♪
♪ Somebody, find me somebody ♪
♪ Find me somebody ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ Can anybody find me ♪
♪ Da, da, da ♪
♪ Somebody to love ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Find me, doo, dah ♪
♪ Somebody ♪
♪ Find me, find me somebody to love ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Find me, find me ♪
♪ Somebody ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ To-oo-oo-oo, find me ♪
♪ Oh, anybody ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Anybody, please ♪
♪ Somebody ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ To-oo-oo-oo, find me ♪
♪ Find me ♪
♪ Somebody ♪
♪ Find me somebody to love ♪
♪ To love ♪
(students and faculty applaud)
- Well, thank you, Citations.
You are a versatile group
this year, let me say that.
Opening with fight songs
and closing with Queen
and a little bit of your own mashup
and Leonard Cohen in between.
That you're singing Leonard Cohen
makes me feel like I'm not too
old for this job, actually.
(students and faculty laugh)
Thank you, let's have another
hand for The Citations.
(students and faculty applaud)
So I hope that was as inspiring
to you as it was to me.
And it is now my pleasure to
introduce you to Sharon Kugler,
Yale's University Chaplain.
Chaplain Kugler joined the
Yale community in 2007,
bringing with her over
two decades of experience
in ministry, in higher education,
interfaith collaboration, and
pastoral and social ministry.
Over the past 14 years,
she has cultivated a chaplaincy
that serves the needs
of the richly, diverse religious
and spiritual traditions
of our faculty, students, and staff.
For our campus community, she
facilitates deeper dialogue,
increased access, personal growth,
creative educational opportunities,
and pastoral leadership.
Chaplain Kugler is also a lecturer
of interreligious
engagement and chaplaincy
at the Yale Divinity School.
And so I will turn things
over to Chaplain Kugler
for the benediction.
- In his work, "Today is a New Day,"
a piece that is both poem and
invitation to young scholars,
the 2015 U.S. Poet Laureate,
Juan Felipe Herrera wrote,
"Today is a new day.
You are that new day!
Today you are that new time.
Now visible, now prepared,
now filled with eagerness and hope.
You are that hope.
The wild born vista of new horizons."
Students, faculty, staff, loved ones.
You are, each and everyone,
part of a whole new Yale,
a new circle of scholars and friends.
What Yale was yesterday
is not what it is today
or will be tomorrow because of you.
Your questions will emerge and then bloom.
And your fresh intellect will carry us all
to a new discovery, to a new day.
As we prepare to take our next steps
into these new discoveries,
we note our anxieties,
but we also lift up our
considerable abilities
and the remarkable fellowship
we will come to share
in community.
Let curiosity nourish us
and compassion guide us
as this new creation unfolds.
On this day and every day forward,
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless our every breath.
May we go in shalom,
in salam, in shanti,
may we go in peace?
This is our new day.
Let us begin.